[Applaudissements]
mon nom est céline trad
et aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter une
partie de mon histoire à billets oui je
sais cette déclaration peut paraître un
peu surprenante mais c'est un clin
d'oeil à des phrases qu'on m'a souvent
répété à partir du moment où j'ai décidé
de changer de vie tu sais pour toi
désormais ça va être compliqué non mais
on dit ça pour ton bien mais qui vas-tu
intéressés céline tran katsuni oui ça
c'est exotique ça faisait fantasmer mais
qui va vouloir écouter alors que tu te
rhabiller et puis tu t'es mon très
déshabillée alors qui va te prendre au
sérieux
non mais il va falloir te faire une
raison toute ta vie tu vas devoir porter
l'étiquette actrice porno c'est marrant
comme des mises en garde peuvent sonner
comme des condamnations ou des
prédictions le monde serait plaint de
juger de médium moi vous me parler
d'étiquettes
je pense à mes fringues et la plupart du
temps j'ai des coupes et vous vous en
avez des étiquettes vous en donner êtes
vous vous même conscient de celle qu on
vous attribue
et puis j'aimerais savoir est-ce qu'on
est censé y en avoir une ou plusieurs
est ce que sur chacune et préciser une
date de péremption
en ce qui concerne l'éthique est actrice
porno ou travailleuses du sexe je trouve
ça triste qu'on en arrive à croire qu'il
faut nécessairement les dissimuler rené
et cela me porte à me poser cette
question à quel point une étiquette de
déterminer notre vie quel point accordé
au jugement des autres mais aussi à
celui qu'on se porte alors en ce qui me
concerne je ne suis pas tombé dans le
porno
en fait j'ai même plongé avec
enthousiasme je n'ai pas été abusé
durant mon enfance n'est pas été menacée
pour me rendre sur les tournages j'ai eu
la chance de grandir dans une bulle de
confort avec le soutien de mes parents
qui ont tout fait pour que je puisse
accéder à des études supérieures et à
leur grand regret et bien j'ai décidé de
quitter les bancs de sciences po pour un
jour à 21 ans
faire le choix du porno et à ce moment
là pour moi ce choix est juste il répond
une soif d'expérimentation pour
apprendre à me connaître
et oui ce n'est pas héroïque mais ce
n'est pas non plus honteux
c'est le besoin de répondre à une quête
personnelle sensorielle oui identitaire
et durant ce cheminement et bien je
trouve pur plaisir et croyez moi ça va
bien au delà de l'aspect sexuel
douze ans plus tard je suis devenue
l'actrice x française la plus reconnue
dans le monde
38 howard internationaux une carrière
aux états unis on me reconnaît dans la
rue on sourit même jusqu'au fin fond de
l'australie oui je t'ai étonné si je
vous dis ça c'est parce qu'aujourd'hui
tout cela m'apparaît comme un énorme
mirage alors oui cette notoriété je vais
gagner j'ai travaillé pour et ce n'a pas
toujours été facile mais je n'oublie pas
l'adolescente que j'ai pu être celle qui
regardait ses pieds en cours de danse
celle qui nous est pas levé la main en
classe qui restaient en marge des
groupes
celle qui a vécu son premier baiser à 17
ans oui alors forcément ça me fait
sourire parce que je me dis quand même
j'ai bien réussi mon coup
en fait je me suis tellement amusée à
incarner une sorte de wonder woman du
sexe que les gens fini par croire que
j'en ai une
c'est fou comme lorsqu'on joue un rôle
avec sincérité mais on finit par se
fondre en lui et donc à 32 ans je suis
katsuni stars internationales du mix et
rien d'autre et c'est bien ça le
problème
je me suis tellement investi dans ma
carrière que moi même je ne saurais dire
si je suis capable de faire autre chose
mon métier et ma fonction
il me définis aux yeux du monde et je me
sens de plus en plus en décalage avec ce
monde
suis-je toujours à la bonne place alors
que je constate que la plupart de mes
vidéos en tout cas beaucoup d'entre
elles se retrouvent en accès gratuit sur
internet accessible à tous enfants y
compris cette question je ne me la pose
est pas quand j'ai commencé il n'y avait
pas internet
c'était une histoire d'adultes est ce
que j'ai toujours envie de tourner des
scènes de plus en plus formaté par
l'obsession de générer du trafic et puis
moi aussi j'ai changé à ce moment là je
suis amoureuse et ça me bouleverse
pour la première fois de ma vie je
ressent le désir de devenir maman
c'est pas rien alors oui
je crois qu'à ce moment là j'ai envie
que ma sexualité mon corps deviennent
intime
je suis ce que j'appelle la stratégie de
l'instinct je suis à l'écouté de ce que
je ressens la dans le ventre et du cou
eh bien je plaque tout bon alors c'est
drôle drôle parce que on est fin 2012 à
quelques jours soit disant de la fin du
monde je me dis qu'en bas le timing est
plutôt bien choisi sauf que je n'avais
pas du tout prévu ça et je n'ai pas de
plan b
autant dire que je rentre dans une belle
phase de remise en question qui va durer
un état de crise et bien c'est cette
histoire que je veux vous raconter tout
ce que je vous ai dit jusqu'à présent
prenez ça comme du contexte le porno
c'était un échauffement
parce que vraiment pour moi tout
commence là alors je me retrouve seul
face à moi-même
dans ce bel appartement à nîmes où
certes de nouveau célibataire
je fais le constat et je me dis bah oui
c'est vrai j'ai réussi d'une certaine
manière mais qu'est ce qu'il reste deux
mois maintenant que je ne suis plus
katsuni comment suis-je censé me
comporter dans le monde réel
comment ça va se passer par exemple face
à un homme qui va me plaire
comment l'abordez comment me présenter
avant c'était bien pratique
j'avais juste à dire à mon agent et
j'aime bien cet acteur tu pourrais
bouquet avec mais là hors tournage en
fait je ne sais pas draguer est-ce que
céline va suffire je ne suis même pas
sûr d'ailleurs de savoir faire l'amour
oui cette sexualité de tournage m'a plus
sinon clairement je n'aurais pas adopté
mais elle a été tellement systématiser
poussé à l'extrême
je ne saurais dire et comment ça va se
passer aussi professionnellement
est-ce que sur un cv par exemple on peut
écrire alors de 2000 à 2013 championne
de porno 38 titres vous m'embaucher
non vraiment à ce moment là c'est confus
en fait mes repères ou complètement
basculé c'est effrayant mais en même
temps je dois dire que c'est assez
stimulant en fait je ressens comme une
énergie nouvelle
mais sens sont en éveil je porte un
nouveau regard sur le monde
finalement c'est une renaissance alors
renaître c'est bien beau mais pour
devenir qui et quand on parle identité
et bien bien souvent on parle d'image et
je regarde les dernières photos que j'ai
posté sur les réseaux sociaux et je me
vois lascive au bord d'une piscine
hollywoodienne en bikini alors oui je
trouve jolie bataille heures sinon je ne
l'aurais pas poster bien sûr sauf que
tout ça n'a plus aucun sens en fait qui
me force à rester dans un système où il
faut nécessairement séduire pour exister
qui m'empêche de m'exprimer autrement je
sais j'ai cette étiquette star du x mais
je suis bien plus à moi de partager
autrement autre chose à moi de me
réinventer
on est donc en 2013 j'ai toute cette
énergie à disposition je m'inscris en
école de cirque en formation
professionnelle et je me retrouve cinq
heures par jour sur un tapis
d'entraînement j'ai 33 ans milieu de
jeunes prodiges je suis la plus âgée la
moins compétentes la moins endurantes un
vrai boulet et c'est parfait en fait mon
statut c'est débutante j'ai tout à
apprendre
j'en arrive à participer à mon premier
spectacle où je dois présenter une
petite démonstration de tissu aérien
pas trop non plus puisqu'il s'agit d'une
discipline qui consiste à monter dans
les airs se suspendre à deux grands pans
de tissus pour effectuer une
chorégraphie
bah oui un jour j'ai vu un numéro ça m'a
fait rêver je me suis dit je veux
apprendre à faire ça
sauf que je suis sur le point de monter
sur scène et je suis tétanisé bien sûr
j'ai peur qu'on trouve ma performance
complètement nul
et c'est peut-être le cas d'ailleurs
mais surtout je suis terrifiée
et si quelqu'un interrompre le spectacle
mais vous allez donc pas vu mais
regardez là c'est une actrice porno là
devant nos enfants
sauf que rien de ça n'arrive je fais mon
numéro
le public applaudit et je me retrouve
devant lui anonyme est pourtant reconnue
croyez moi pour moi c'est un petit
miracle dans le spectacle suivant jose
une prise de risque et je présente un
numéro en duo humoristique clownesque et
ça marche
je suis donc capable de faire rire des
enfants
là je me dis mes parents vont pas le
croire bon en même temps j me croira
roman c'est un peu normal il est temps
pour moi de revenir en france et je me
retrouve devant la caméra
j'ai le plaisir de d'incarner un
personnage qu'on m'offre dans une série
qui en plus destiné à un public familial
j'ai le personnage le plus prudes de la
série le plus coincé
je suis ravi et là ça fait naître en moi
un nouvel objectif
en fait j'ai envie d'être comédienne
part oui avec dialogues et avec
vêtements mais je mise sur le cinéma
d'action
bah oui fan girl alors je m'entraîne et
je m'entraîne et j'ai la chance d'être
coaché par une équipe de cascadeurs
professionnels qui est génial et qui
croient en moi qui m'encouragent
je me remets au karaté je m'inscris
haute et points d'eau je passe mes deux
ceintures noires cela prend un peu de
temps à force de travail ont fini par me
proposer un rôle dans un film d'arts
martiaux au cambodge
et là je me dis mais ça y est ça devient
concret c'est bon je suis en train de
trouver ma place et crack
je me retourne littéralement le pied
durant une répétition de scènes de
combat et là j'ai le choix entre quitter
le tournage est resté bien sûr je reste
mon corps mon choix il va me le faire
payer un peu cher les médecins sont ces
petits car on n'est pas sûr que vous
retrouviez vraiment votre pied
alors j'ai 37 ans déjà et on me répète
que ben oui ça fait un peu âgé quand
même pour se mettre à briller à l'écran
pour une femme
et il faut reconnaître aussi que je n'ai
pas les traits de la française typique à
laquelle on peut s'identifier et puis
j'avais oublié bah oui elle est là sur
mon front probablement parce que moi je
la vois pas mais on me la rappelle cette
étiquette actrice porno et ça met mal à
l'aise alors me le répète ne te fais pas
d'illusions et en plus je boite que
faire s'adapter il n'y a ni justice ni
garantie et je me dis que si je ne peux
poser le pied à terre et bien c'est
peut-être un signe qu'il faut remonter
dans les airs alors je reprends mon
entraînement de tissu aérien
ça me permet de me vider la tête parce
que clairement à ce moment là je ne sens
pas très bien je n'arrive plus à me
projeter
mais j'ai une coach au nord une femme
extraordinaire
une athlète est elle est là elle elle
croit en moi et en fait ça me donne des
ailes
bah oui je sais c'est pas incroyable
peut-être pour vous mais en tout cas
pour moi ça l'est ce qui est incroyable
c'est que quelques mois plus tard ça me
mène à présenter mon propre numéro de
tissu aérien sur la scène d'un théâtre à
paris je rappelle quand même qu'à la
base j'ai le vertige mais là je m'envole
comme quoi je pense vraiment qu'on peut
s'offrir des petits miracles et c'est le
temps pour moi c'est le bon moment pour
partager mon histoire alors
j'entreprends l'écriture de mon livre ça
me permet de faire le tri dans tout ce
que j'ai vécu dans tirer le meilleur
pour continuer la suite justement pour
écrire cette suite et cette suite et
bien justement elle est sous forme
d'apprentissage et une soif énorme
il se trouve que le yoga m'a beaucoup
aidé dans ma rééducation et je veux
explorer davantage
alors qu'est ce que je fais je m'inscris
en formation professionnelle et l'aja
prend une leçon
très belle moi qui aime tant le
challenge physique j'apprends à m'en
détacher
j'apprends à me détacher de cette
recherche de résultats de performance en
fait j'apprends tout simplement à
respirer à trouver l'équilibré à être
présente pour moi pour les autres mais
c'est pas tout j'ai aussi envie
d'explorer le sens du toucher
différemment d'aborder le corps dans sa
dimension physiologique énergétique et
je me tourne vers les massages là je
découvre toute une variété de techniques
et de cultures différentes massage thaï
du massage chinois du massage
ayurvédique californien suédois je
découvre les subtilités des muscles des
fascias des articulations et comment
toucher un corps tout simplement pour
lui apporter du bien-être
parmi les personnes que je masse et bien
il ya des personnes âgées certaines en
situation de handicap des femmes
enceintes
et oui des hommes des hommes qui
connaissent très bien mon passé et ça se
passe bien ils me font confiance je leur
fais confiance aussi et pour chacun j'ai
la même intention prendre soin de leur
apporter du bien-être du lâcher prise de
la bienveillance mais j'ai aussi envie
de m'occuper de ce qui se passe là dans
leur tête et dans leur émotion il se
trouve qu'au cours de ma vie l'hypnose
ericksonienne m'a beaucoup aidé c'est
une technique de développement qui vous
permet pour résumer et bien de puiser
dans vos ressources d'accéder à votre
potentiel
il y à vraiment pour moi quelque chose
de magique là dedans ça aussi ça peut
contribuer à réaliser des petits
miracles
alors je me dis mais c'est génial il
faut que je me forme à ça bah oui du
coup je m'inscris en formation
professionnelle une fois cus et c'est
parfait parce que cela va me permettre
d'accompagner les personnes qui me
contacte ça fait des années en fait que
des hommes des femmes parfois même des
adolescents envoient leurs questions ils
ont peur ils ont peur d'être jugés ils
ont besoin d'être rassurés parfois ils
me parlent de sexualité mais aussi de
leur envie d'explorer de pouvoir
s'autoriser tout simplement
et ils n'ont pas envie qu'on leur
rajoute des étiquettes alors et
s'adresse à moi et vous savez quand on
parle de sexualité finalement on ne
parle pas forcément de sexe on parle
avant tout de rapport à soi de
l'estiment qu'on se porte de rapport à
son corps de la relation à l'autre on
parle d'intimité et donc finalement
voilà elle est là ma place on et fin
j'ouvre mon cabinet à paris en tant que
coach en bien-être et en sexualité
alors bien sûr on a mis en garde dans
mais toi tu vas faire des massages toi
tu donnes des conseils en sexualité à
des hommes qui t'ont vu dénudée mais
vraiment tu cherches les problèmes oui
moi mais moi ce qui m'intéresse surtout
ce sont les solutions
j'ai vraiment la team conviction que
chacun et chacune d'entre nous mérite sa
place sur cette planète nous sommes
vivants mais à chacun de nous de décider
comment l'occuper nous habitons un corps
ressentons pensons avec et quoi qu'on
puisse nous dire eh bien tout cela nous
appartient nous sommes libres les aussi
responsable à nous de prendre soin de
nous en fait on n'a pas besoin de d'être
parfait ou d'être le meilleur pour
s'autoriser à s'aimer une partie de
votre passé vous paraît détestable donc
voilà reproche ça fera un excellent
temps vrai maintenant posez vous la
question
que voulez vous y faire pousser
mon nom est céline tran et je suis
auteur scénariste directrice de
collection coach en bien-être et en
sexualité et je m'arrêtais là parce que
je suis aussi d'autres choses mais ça va
encore ajouter des étiquettes est en
fait ce n'est pas important
rien est immuable peut-être que je ferai
autre chose en 10 ans ou 20 ans ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'aujourd'hui je sais qui
je suis et je tiens à vous remercier
pour m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]